ce week-end le campus de beaulieu à
rennes s'est transformé en piste du bol
d'or version solex c'était la 33e
édition du rock'n solex et le plus vieux
festival étudiant qui existe reportage
de roger band a yo et sert jeune fabre
ombissa crachouille et ça pétarade après
l'épreuve technique d'hier et la course
de vitesse c'est l'endurance qui
commence sur le circuit improvisé dans
le campus
la course se déroule à train d'enfer au
total 400 pilotes sont venus de tout
l'hexagone pour 150 solex dans le
paddock
ce sont les derniers réglages de ces
drôles de machines m'a crevé donc à la
truite sur l'épreuve
l'heure est à l'image en train de gagner
deux types de solex sont retenus pour la
course
les originaux et les prototypes des
prototypes qui donnent souvent du fil à
retordre à ses rois du bricolage
justement la ville
à pékin il est combien 7e les pilotes
n'ont qu'un but faire le maximum de
tours en moins de six heures certains
bolides peuvent même atteindre 90 km
heure
intérêt il est surtout historique parce
que ça fait 34 ans que m
le but c'est de perpétuer salle plus
longtemps possible encore question
décibels toutes les audaces sont
permises
d'ailleurs ici une seule devise pourquoi
faire simple quand on peut faire
compliqué